everything you've ever known is a lie at
least when it comes to superhero films
maybe it's time to put the Justice
League and Avengers on the sidelines as
we speculate on some crazy superhero
film theories that could just change
everything
Stan Lee is the watcher you probably
thought Stan Lee was making cameos in
every Marvel film just because he's
awesome but there might be another
reason maybe he's actually playing the
role of uatu the watcher who well the
watcher is a cosmic being tasked with
cataloguing what happens on earth
without interfering he watches
everything from the background exactly
like Stan Lee could stand really be an
extraterrestrial a heir that explains
everything
Wonder Woman and Aquaman are Kryptonian
remember in Man of Steel when Clark Kent
found a craft Kryptonian scout ship on
earth the ship had been sitting in ice
for over 18,000 years
which begs the question what happened to
the cretonne ian's on that ship well
some fans think that they survived and
use their tech to establish an
underwater colony which eventually
became Aquaman's Hall of atlantis others
suggest they founded Wonder Woman's
Amazonian Society of the mascara or both
making them all Kryptonian sounds weird
but it would at least explain where all
these super people come from Jared
Leto's Joker is Jason Todd stop us if
you've heard this one but there are some
people who think Jared Leto's version of
the Joker from Suicide Squad is actually
Batman's former sidekick Robin holy
Benedict Arnold in Batman vs Superman
Bruce Wayne's Batcave had a memorial set
up for what was presumably the last
Robin Jason Todd in the comics the Joker
severely beats Todd with a crowbar
before killing him in an explosion he
was brought back from the grave went
nuts and as a twisted tribute to his
attacker took up the Joker's previous
costumed identity the Red Hood what if
little Joker is actually a crazed Jason
Todd taking up the mantle of the villain
who ruined his life while director Zack
Snyder has said in interviews that Robin
was indeed killed by the Joker he may be
trying to redirect fans from a big
reveal now that would be a really good
joke
we met star-lords dad in guardians of
the galaxy
one of the biggest dangling plot threads
in guardians of galaxy is the identity
of peter's star-lord quills father but
what if he was in the movie after all we
know quills father's an alien and that
star-lord has the ability to use an
infinity stone without exploding which
is kind of a big deal who else can do
that Adam warlock a weird space hippie
who hatched from a cocoon which appeared
to be part of the collectors display did
it contain star Lords dad we won't know
until the sequel the Red Skull still
lives the last time we saw the Red Skull
the Hydra leader was fighting Captain
America for control of a tesseract the
skull grabbed it only to have a portal
open and suck him in apparently wiping
them out of existence so where did the
Red Skull go
since the tesseract is capable of
anything there's no end to the
shenanigans he could be up to wherever
he ended up our money is on the Red
Skull to survive and eventually return
to the Marvel Universe stronger than
ever before cut off one lemon all that
right thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which superhero
movie theories should have made the list